moi j'ai deux filles je voudrais quand
même pas qu'elle fasse du vélo quoi je
bouffais 1968
voilà comment était perçue le cyclisme
féminin à l'époque des propos misogynes
sexiste dont regorge des archives de la
télé
tenez écouter le commentaire de ce
journaliste c'était en 1955 à l'occasion
du tout premier tour de france féminin
les massages dans ce cas ne sont plus
une simple question d'esthétique et nos
courses hier c'est leur titre officiel
le mot coureuses n'ayant pas été retenue
l'eau coursières donc on accepter la
bande de sparadrap qui doit le raffermir
les reins ainsi s'est envolé si l'on
peut dire
le premier tour de france cycliste
féminin et ça continue les années
suivantes
1984 le tour de france féminin revient
après 29 ans d'absence au programme dix
huit étapes 1000 km de course
trente six participantes est au bout
toujours les mêmes remarques un peu
lourde 1984 année bénie pour les
suffragettes après le tour de france le
tour des miss est à côté des géants de
la route voici les mignonnes du bitume
est sur le bord de la route
du côté des spectateurs on ne peut pas
dire que ce soit vraiment mieux 1984
autres attaques sexistes même de la part
des cyclistes masculin cette fois c'est
laurent fignon qui se lâche complètement
toujours pendant le tour de france
on souffre ailleurs pourquoi pas mais
pas sur tous les sports les femmes
souffrent quand elles font un effort
mais ça se voit beaucoup plus sur le
vélo et
trois ans plus tard en 1987
c'est au tour du cycliste marc madiot de
se distinguer la star du vélo français
est invité sur le plateau de sport était
avec jeannie longo juste après une étape
du tour de france
et voici ce qu'il pensait du cyclisme
féminin attention c'est sans filtre et
des sports qui sont atteints il ya des
sports qui sont féminins voir une femme
danse et pour moi c'est très joli voir
une femme joue au foot je reconnais par
une femme danse et c'est très joli voir
une femme joue au football c'est moche
et jose il tient et vous voir une voir
une femme sur un vélo c'est moche c'est
monde
ça n'engage que moi aujourd'hui il est
toujours difficile pour les femmes
cyclistes de se faire entendre
d'ailleurs c'est un sport
majoritairement masculin sur son 5000
licenciés
seuls onze mille trois cents sont des
femmes le public s'intéresse au sport
féminin ça je dis je le redis et je
crois que les médias doivent comprendre
ça et doivent retransmettre aussi bien
le sport féminin que ce format 2d
[Musique]